[Musica]
Diciamo che l'inverno io porta pure la
sciarpetta per stare più in tema ma
chiedo scusa ho questo tipo di voce
perché il titolo è L'inverno sta
arrivando sicuramente voi avete visto
Non voglio spoilerare nulla Il trono di
spade Il trono di spade per sette
stagioni parla di Casate che litigano
tra di loro discussioni situazioni
complesse tutte quante per cercare di
arrivare alla conquista del famigerato
Trono di Spade ad un certo punto
all'ottava stagione un pochino prima
subentra qualcosa che cambia totalmente
la prospettiva della serie cioè subentra
un nemico molto molto più grande e viene
utilizzato un refren che è L'inverno sta
arrivando Ecco la situazione italiana è
molto simile le Casate del Trono di
Spade si mettono insieme e combattono
tutte insieme contro questo inverno
contro questo nemico molto molto più
grande quello che sta capitando in
Italia molto simile per quanto riguarda
un altro tipo d'inverno che l'inverno
demografico se ne parla ci sono commenti
estemporanei legati ai vari dati Istat
che escono di tanto in tanto però poi
alla fine non si fa nulla Ecco la
situazione è talmente grave che siamo
chiamati a fare squadra tutti insieme
siamo chiamati a rompere lo schema delle
divisioni rompere lo schema dei Guelfi e
degli Ghibellini siamo chiamati a
mettere insieme maggioranze opposizione
siamo chiamati come nel Trono di Spade a
fare squadra e siamo Tutti convocati non
è che c'è qualcuno che può dirsi non
convocato perché questo è un po' la
situazione vedete nelle slide nel 1918
nascevano X centinaia di migliaia di
persone grosso modo nel
1947 cioè diciamo durante la Seconda
Guerra Mondiale nascevano circa 800 mila
persone poi a poco a poco un crollo dal
2008 in poi la situazione è
assolutamente compromessa Perché Perché
non si riesce a risalire quest'anno
dovete immaginare sono nate circa
393.000 persone
393.000 persone sono nate però 700 mila
sono morte è come se noi perdessimo Ogni
anno una città come Bari durante il
lockdown Quindi durante diciamo la
pandemia una città come varie è
diventata una città come Firenze e c'è
da immaginarla la scena è come se
scomparisse totalmente una città di
questa grandezza 320 350 mila persone
ogni anno se andiamo a vedere poi i dati
relativi alle proiezioni future come
vedete la situazione andrà sempre peggio
al 2070 si parla di 250.000 nuovi nati
ma non è assolutamente diciamo
reale perché ci sono tutta una serie di
fattori che adesso vi dirò Questi sono i
dati che ci aspettano diminuisce il
numero in assoluto delle persone aumenta
il numero degli anziani ma soprattutto
aumenta anche lo squilibrio
intergenerazionale Cioè ci sono molti
più anziani rispetto ai giovani
professor brangiardo presidente
dell'istat parla di oltre centinaia di
migliaia di ultracentenari nei prossimi
anni Questa è una bella notizia che
dovremmo festeggiare ma dovremmo
festeggiarla qualora Appunto ci fosse un
equilibrio altrimenti questo produrrà
una serie di criticità prima però di
parlare delle possibili soluzioni mi
farebbe piacere
aiutare a portare come contributo quello
di un cambio di prospettiva su alcune
situazioni perché ci sono delle dei
refren ci sono delle diciamo no fake
news però diciamo delle situazioni che
noi ci raccontiamo che non sono così
come realmente sono la prima è Vabbè
alla fine la natalità riguarda un c'è
una certa tipologia di persone non
riguarda tutti riguarda una certa
categoria riguarda una certa componente
religiosa riguarda chi ai figli riguarda
no riguarda tutti questi dati sono
impressionanti e sono spaventosi potevo
trovare una slide migliore ma vi
assicuro non c'era se voi vedete il
quadratino rosso e l'Italia è l'Italia
nel 2017 è l'Italia nel 2030 dove ha il
nono posto per quanto riguarda il PIL e
poi c'è un crollo enorme Per quanto
riguarda il PIL dell'Italia
se poi vedete arriva fino al 25esimo
posto nel 2050 mentre invece ci sono
Paesi con una natalità differente con
natalità positiva che crescono ad
esempio al caso della Svezia che quella
contornata di azzurro questo dato che ha
pubblicato Il Sole 24 Ore recentemente
mostra che cosa che l'Italia non è più o
non sta diventando non sarà più
considerata un grande paese e questo non
riguarda semplicemente le persone di una
certa categoria non riguarda solamente
gli anziani non riguarda solamente i
giovani non riguarda solamente le
persone di destra o di sinistra riguarda
assolutamente tutti riguarda ogni
persona perché il Pilar a che fare con
la ricchezza di un paese
altra chiave di lettura che voglio
totalmente sfatare è quella ed è un
refrain ancora più comune che è una
questione culturale ci sono addirittura
ex ministri ho partecipato a degli
eventi dove si parlava di questo tema
che hanno detto i giovani italiani tra
uno spritz e un figlio hanno scelto lo
spritz Questa è una delle cose più
brutte che abbia mai sentito perché
banalizza la complessità enorme in cui
si trovano i giovani italiani Oggi molte
persone pensano che
sia una questione culturale Cioè non c'è
più la voglia i giorni di oggi sono dei
bamboccioni Ah le famiglie di un tempo
erano quelle che ci credevano
maggiormente che comunque stavano più
attente mia nonna diceva che dove si
mangia in quattro Ci si mangia anche in
cinque insomma questi luoghi comuni
Non è una questione semplicemente
culturale cultura ed economia si
intrecciano a vicenda l'esempio è questa
slide questa slide mostra che cosa il
desiderio di figli che hanno le donne
italiane e qui ha preso un lasso di
tempo molto ampio dal 1963 al 1983 il
desiderio è la data di nascita di queste
donne il desiderio di natalità quindi il
desiderio di figli e 2,4 per donna
se andiamo a vedere poi qual è il tasso
di natalità in Italia è
1,4,24 tra il 2,4 e l'1,24
c'è tutto il problema del nostro paese
c'è il fatto che non riusciamo a mettere
i giovani e le donne nelle condizioni di
realizzare i loro sogni lavorativi e
familiari in questo 1,16 che manca in
questo Delta ci sono le dimissioni in
bianco ci sono il dover scegliere tra
lavoro e la famiglia Ci sono il fatto
che per prendere una casa devi fare i
salti mortali e devi andare con i
genitori c'è tutta la frustrazione di
chi non riesce a realizzare i suoi sogni
e che mostra in maniera molto molto
chiara che non è semplicemente una
questione culturale ma anche economica
in Italia la nascita di un figlio la
seconda causa di povertà
La prima è la perdita del lavoro di uno
dei componenti della famiglia La seconda
è la nascita di un figlio voi potete
capire che in una situazione di questo
tipo è tutto molto grave È tutto molto
complesso è come un cane che si morde la
coda un'altra fake news è quella in base
alla quale siamo troppi nel mondo un
figlio inquina i dati sono
impressionanti tra un po' diventeremo 10
miliardi Sì è vero la popolazione
mondiale sta crescendo ma per poi
crollare già i dati diciamo dell'ONU nel
1980 davano delle proiezioni che non si
sono verificate perché questo perché
questo dato a mio modo di vedere
impressionante se ne parla poco dovete
immaginare che nel
1973 nel mondo nel mondo quindi non solo
in Italia quindi ha a che fare anche con
i paesi africani con i paesi asiatici
c'era 1, milioni di
spermatozoi ogni millilitro
nel 2018 sono diventati 49 milioni
quindi oltre ad esserci una questione
economica oltre ad esserci una questione
culturale c'è anche come vedete una
questione enorme dal punto di vista
sanitario E questo è solo l'aspetto
maschile Poi c'è tutto l'aspetto anche
femminile che ha tutta un'altra serie di
situazioni
collegate Allora che cosa si può fare
si deve necessariamente provare a
cambiare prospettiva perché tra un po'
crolla il sistema pensionistico tra un
po' crolla il sistema sanitario tra un
po' crolle il Welfare già le scuole
stanno chiudendo già ci sono situazioni
molto difficili per quanto riguarda i
piccoli comuni che oltre a vivere la
situazione della deatalità vivono anche
lo spopolamento e quindi siamo in un
certo senso Tutti convocati Che cosa
possiamo fare noi possiamo cambiare
prospettiva ciascuno deve fare il suo
pezzetto Ognuno ha un pezzetto da fare
lo Stato deve fare lo stato che cosa
deve fare politiche familiari Sul
modello francese e Sul modello tedesco
lo Stato può creare una fiscalità
finalmente a dimensione familiare può
aumentare l'assegno unico può creare le
premesse perché giovani possano prendere
la casa senza dover fare i salti mortali
ma anche la regione può fare molto la
regione Deve necessariamente creare le
premesse perché ci sia un accesso al
credito le regioni può diminuire l'IRPEF
i comuni devono fare asili nido rette
rette per quanto riguarda le mense
comunali e gli asinido più basse le
aziende sono chiamati a coinvolgere il
mondo e aiutare a creare le premesse
perché ci sia un armonizzazione Tra il
lavoro familiare il lavoro di cura e il
lavoro e che non ci sia quella scelta di
cui parlavo prima però anche noi siamo
chiamati a fare qualcosa anche noi tu
sei un padre Beh a seconda di come torni
a casa e ti butti sul divano davanti ai
tuoi figli e magari stai lì in maniera
distratta e non metti attenzione Beh lì
un figlio matura la decisione di
paternità o no sei un professore beh
ai tempi dei miei genitori il futuro era
una promessa ai miei tempi è
un'incognita Per quanto riguarda i miei
figli sarà una minaccia ciascuno è
chiamato a fare il suo pezzetto perché
nessun altro lo potrà fare concludendo
se io non ho fatto un figlio ma 5 figli
non è perché me lo posso permettere non
è perché in Italia conviene non è perché
non c'ho il televisore
lo dico perché la grande battuta che
solitamente si fa
è semplicemente perché è bello
Al di là delle questioni economiche
sociali delle pensioni c'è una bellezza
che dobbiamo tornare a vivere c'è
un'opportunità incredibile noi non siamo
animali che dobbiamo proseguire la
specie e fare un figlio Non è un obbligo
Ci mancherebbe altro Ma oggi è libero di
non farlo Chi non vuole farlo ma non è
libero di farlo chi vuole farlo perché
la seconda causa di povertà c'è una
bellezza che ci porta avanti da secoli a
continuare a donare la vita e questo
dono Fondamentalmente lo facciamo perché
non c'è niente di più bello che
condividere questa vita con qualcuno
grazie
[Applauso]